nasa is the american space giant
responsible for sending people to space
for decades
and even putting people on the moon the
rich history
and sky-high accomplishments of nasa are
known around the world today
but for the last couple of decades it
seems like nasa has hit a plateau
in terms of innovation and advancement
they've contracted out several
tremendous tasks to private companies
like spacex
blue origin and rocket lab meanwhile
they've been working on something called
the space launch system
which seems to be extremely expensive
especially in comparison to the
competition
so what happened to nasa
well starting off one of the first tasks
that nasa didn't do so hard in was of
course
the space shuttle the space shuttle was
an extremely ambitious program
and many of its goals were achieved for
instance
the space shuttle boasts a massive
payload capacity of 29 000 kilograms
to put that in perspective the falcon
9's payload capacity to low earth orbit
is 22
800 kilograms and that was developed
decades later
aside from this the space shuttle would
play an integral role in the
construction of the international space
station
as it was the only rocket ship at the
time that was capable of carrying many
of its parts
evidently the space shuttle was quite an
important development
however it failed at some of its core
goals such as providing reliable rocket
reusability
and reducing the cost of space flight
the space shuttle was reusable
but this didn't really help much till
very recently
the space shuttle held the record for
the fastest turnaround blocking in at
just 54 days
but when it comes to the reusability of
the space shuttle it wasn't the
turnaround time that was the biggest
problem
the real killer was the cost of reusing
the space shuttle
at the end of today the nasa space
shuttle program cost a massive 209
billion dollars
which allowed for 135 flights that's the
same
as 1.55 billion dollars per flight
at that rate constructing 135 space
shuttles may have come out to about the
same price
nasa was well aware of this massive
shortfall and this is one of the main
reasons they stopped the space shuttle
program
though it was unfortunate that this
decision would strip america of being
able to launch astronauts to space from
american soil
this allowed nasa to get a clean slate
and start over
this decision would lead them to start
development of the space launch system
but the news so far about this is not
very promising
in fact nasa themselves estimate that a
single launch of the space launch system
will cost up to two billion dollars and
that's not even including development
costs meanwhile
spacex's upcoming starship rocket not
only has a larger payload capacity
but it also costs significantly less
spacex is hoping to bring down the cost
of starship launches down to just 2
million
but even if they underestimated this
amount by 100 eggs
a starship launch will only cost a tenth
of the price of an sls launch
as you can see nasa is not nearly as
innovative today
as they were during the apollo days but
why
well unfortunately in my opinion the
primary reason nasa has stalled for so
long
is politics nasa is a government
organization
and is funded by taxpayer dollars as a
result the president and congress have
significant control
over an organization that they usually
don't even have a very good
understanding about
moreover even if they do have a solid
science background
it's likely that politicians will favor
funding organizations
and programs that will help them get
reelected as opposed to organizations
that have waning interest
the truth is even though nasa is an
extremely important organization
helping us travel and colonize beyond
our own planet
public interest in space has been waning
since the moon landing
you see during the 1960s and 1970s
space exploration was a sense of pride
for the average american
as tensions regarding the cold war were
at a peak as a result
politicians were extremely willing to
fund nasa as that helped them garner
massive public support
once america won the space race though
by placing people on the moon
the average american's interest in space
exploration quickly dwindled away
for them reaching the moon as jfk
envisioned was the climax
and the next major space event that
would get the average person riled up
again
was reaching mars though improving
rocket reusability
and setting up a space station would lay
the foundation for eventually reaching
mars
these weren't the most exciting of tasks
and so the average person slowly lost
interest
in fact a poll conducted in 2018
revealed that only 37.9
of respondents thought that returning to
the moon is a priority
right now 42.9 straight up said that
it's not a priority
and 19.2 percent responded that nasa
should focus on sending robots
given this sentiment nasa's funding has
slowly been cut
if you simply look up nasa's funding
figures over the years it would seem
like the overall trend is clearly
upwards
however this doesn't account for
inflation after accounting for inflation
you'll see that in the late 1960s nasa
received a solid 40 billion
annually in funding today nearly 50
years later
they only received half of that at 20
billion annually
moreover during the same time period the
american gdp
has skyrocketed meaning that the tax
revenue has also skyrocketed
as a result not only has nasa's actual
funding itself gone down
but so has the percentage of tax revenue
that nasa receives
in the 1960s nasa was receiving up to
four percent of the total tax revenue
by 2015 though this number had tanked to
just 0.5 percent
aside from poor funding nasa has to get
approval from congress for the structure
of their budget
every year which gives nasa very little
flexibility as to how they spend their
funding
this wouldn't be that big of a deal if
there was a congruent goal
amongst politicians but this has not
been the case
whatsoever for instance just take a look
at the proposed plans
over the past 20 years in 2004
the bush administration would come up
with the constellation program
this program was supposed to put nasa on
the pathway to retire in the space
shuttle program
and reaching the moon the plan called
for the development of a rocket called
ares and a spaceship called oreon nasa
would quickly get to work on this plan
spending over 9 billion over the next
couple of years on research and
development
after president obama took office though
he would scrap the constellation program
and instead approve the sls program this
means that the 9 billion
nasa spent on the constellation program
was basically a complete waste
aside from this obama would also change
the focus of nasa from returning to the
moon
to launching astronauts to mars and
asteroids
but just as this plane was settling in
president trump would come in and shift
the focus of nasa
back to the moon business insider
estimates that this constant switching
of plans from one president to the next
has cost taxpayers 20 billion dollars
in just the last three administrations
in addition to the wasted resources on a
scrap
the constant change of goals no doubt
prevents momentum from building up
making it difficult for nasa to make any
real progress
aside from these various political games
nasa has also suffered from an aging
workforce
astronaut harrison schmidt points out
that the average age of mission control
during the apollo days was just 26 years
old
today the average age of a nasa employee
is closer to 60.
evidently nasa hasn't been that
attractive for the younger generations
in the mid-1900s one of the most common
dreams for kids was becoming an
astronaut
however over the past 50 years so many
interesting opportunities
aside from space have come to fruition
with the help of technology
many kids nowadays want to become
youtubers and gamers and entrepreneurs
the percentage of kids who want to
become astronauts when they grow up
is definitely not as high as it used to
be moreover
for kids that do want to become
astronauts or work in the space industry
nasa is not generally their first choice
spacex's kids today grow up watching
spacex landing their boosters
and sending a roadster to space and
working on reaching mars
this is further accelerated by elon
musk's clever use of social media
every time spacex completes a mission
whether successfully or unsuccessfully
you can bet that elon will be posting
the results to his 43.2 million twitter
followers
as a result young adults don't want to
go work in nasa where things really
haven't moved for decades
they want to go work at spacex with elon
musk
and that brings me on to my final point
witches at nasa themselves have become
self-aware
of their shortcomings given that nasa
has been around for over 60 years
their leaders have come to the
realization that nasa is limited by
government funding
declining public interest and an aging
workforce
thus they have decided to embrace
commercial space flight themselves
nasa administrator jim bradenstein has
placed a heavy focus on using nasa
funding
to fund spacex blue origin and boeing
as the money will likely have a large
impact in the free market
the number of commercial space flight
customers is quite limited
and nasa is no doubt one of the biggest
customers if not the biggest
and they've decided that promoting
competition within the commercial space
flight industry
is the best way they can spend their
money at the end of the day
nasa is the pioneer of space travel and
exploration
over the years they've continuously
tried to push the envelope
but have often failed due to a variety
of external forces they have no control
over
considering this they've decided to fund
private companies that don't have the
same restrictions that nasa does
and while they continue to work on
programs like sls
i have a feeling that their main focus
right now is working with private
companies
to revolutionize the future of space
travel and colonization
what do you guys think is the main
reason for the declining innovation from
nasa
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys thought this video explained
nasa's obstacles well
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one